-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
President Biden and First Lady
Dr. Jill Biden
were photographed yesterday
walking on the beach.
And when there were
one set of footprints,
that's when Jill carried him.
That's right. President Biden
and First Lady Dr. Jill Biden
were photographed
walking on the beach,
while Kevin McCarthy was spotted
walking into the ocean.
President Biden
and Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu reportedly
spoke last night on the phone.
Well, if anything can delay
an Israeli ground invasion,
it's one of Biden's stories.
"Let me tell you
about my track and field days.
They called me -- they called me
the Scranton Flier."
Following reports that
he repeatedly
shared sensitive information
with Australian billionaire
Anthony Pratt,
former President Trump
released a statement
in The New York Times yesterday
and said Pratt is from
a friendly country in Australia,
one of our great allies,
and added, quote,
"I don't know him well,
but he seemed like
a nice person."
He seemed like a nice person?
You know, I don't think
it's safe for America
to have a president
who could be kidnapped
with just a puppy
and a van.
[As Trump] In my defense...
[ Laughter ]
What -- What bad people have
a puppy?
Next thing I know, I'm in a van.
Treated very badly.
[Normally] Senate Minority
Leader Mitch McConnell
appeared yesterday
on "Face the Nation."
This was video, by the way.
[ Laughter ]
That's a clip.
Today marks the House's
third week without a Speaker.
On the plus side, they've
accomplished almost as much as
when they had a Speaker
for three months.
Nine House Republicans
have announced
plans to run for Speaker,
but if you wanted
to see nine people
who have no chance of winning,
just go to a Mets game.
Got it in just
under the wire.
It's still technically baseball
season, so that's not --
And you might be saying,
"The Mets have more
than nine people on their team."
Do they?
After leaving a three-hour-long
closed door meeting last
Thursday with House Republicans,
Wisconsin Congressman
Mike Gallagher told reporters,
quote,
"Temperatures are
really high in there."
Well, that's what happens when
only half of them are vaxed.
That -- I do want to stress,
that's exactly --
that's exactly how
I thought that would go.
Don't think you caught me
off guard.
The remaining games
of a youth football season
in Tennessee
were canceled recently
after parents of opposing teams
got into a fight
and one man allegedly
brandished a gun.
While in Texas,
that's just
a five-yard penalty.
Today was national
TV Talk Show Host Day.
My writers passed around a card,
but it was for Kimmel.
Long Island railroad workers
in New York
recently returned
a lost backpack
with $12,000 to its owner
after she left it onto a train.
Even more surprising,
the woman had $12,000
and still took
the Long Island Railroad.
And finally, Amazon announced
plans last week to begin testing
a humanoid robot called Digit,
which has arms and legs
and can move, grasp,
and handle items like a person,
and most important of all,
no bladder.
And we've maybe miscalculated
what our closer was.
But we can't go back in time.
So I will simply say
that was a monologue, everybody.